yeah
um i don't know i'm not that good i have
to robert does all this stuff for me i
can't do any of it
you're not technologically no but i can
hardly send an email
i just never been online much you're
just more advanced politically but not
technologically not even politically
like i'm dumb politically i'm dumb
technologically but
well i can talk pretty fast yeah you're
a good talker you're i think in the back
in the day you would have been like a
caveman or a storyteller like a
traveling
traveling
crazy man i think i would have been the
type of guy that like sells leeches i if
i was born if i could be born in any era
it'd be the con man
to where like you could say that there
were like ghosts in your blood and you
need to [ __ ] your wife
stuff like that you know
that type of [ __ ] yeah i think it'd be
[ __ ] the emperor's wife
probably not the emperor maybe like a
shopkeep you know i mean mate i don't
know i don't know if i'd be the best at
it but i'd definitely be one of those
guys you'd be in the league with
wrestling in the am i'd be honest
rasputin is probably the best to ever do
it right yeah he he literally was just
like you're sick and you need me to keep
a spell on you and they just stayed sick
yeah right and made all their money yeah
yeah that that's pretty hard to do i'd
be more like you know hey
uh if you let me trust this stick it
will find well on your water like i keep
tigers away you know i mean i would have
found some oil bearing in texas
yeah some low-level grift
so what uh what do you what are you
doing now as a grift what do you do uh
you you're grifting i'm a telemarketer
oh no that's the drift
i mean i just get on the phone and you
know talk
yeah
that's awesome i like it i like it
there's people people like uh you talk
to them in their homes you just suddenly
appear you're like hey you know i don't
mind the awkwardness of this i live in
this
discomfort exactly i make people's days
by letting them know i got good news i
got a product for you you know i got
good i got good news i found your phone
number online you got good news you're
gonna
not have as much money yeah you know
that warranty on your car well we're
about to extend that warranty a whole
lot further let's do this
you do warranties for cars no i sell a
software to laundry mats
oh okay yeah that's sort of like normal
people laundromat owners listen if
you're a laundromat owner
i got you you know
you know there's a struggle phone number
offline you know about all those hangers
and the the tickets that people don't
come back with oh yeah man i'm i go hey
man i'm just like you all right been
studying the business a laundromat for a
decade okay that's what i say to him
i used to sell uh websites to artists
and artists would be like what's your uh
what's your experience and art and i bet
i've been working in art marketing for
10 years yeah which was just like not
true
so you just lie yeah yeah that's awesome
yeah that's part of being rasputin is
good at lying
that's why i think i should have been
what would be your like ideal time
period where your excel your skills
would just like excel
um
now
yeah no i'm killing it now
no um
i would probably do well in a
hunter-gatherer society just
just like i'm like a dog i'm very simple
like just give me two sticks and i'll
like you know make something out of it
and you know just if hands hands-on
stuff would you want to be more hunter
or gatherer
i mean i would like to think i'm a
hunter but you know those guys in india
that like dig holes and make little
mansions yes why don't you do something
like that yeah if you want to be like or
there's that guy in russia that just
makes all his old maybe he's not russia
i just guess he looks slavic to me
but like he just makes like huts
primitive ways too out of like wood huts
and little tools he makes and he doesn't
talk
says nothing primitive technologies or
something yeah i wouldn't be able to do
that because i cannot shut the [ __ ] up
if i had that skill set i'd be doing
that in the entire time there'd be like
you know my commentary over it yeah make
that video six hours long
yeah people would be like wow this guy
is uh good at uh talking and making
things this guy hasn't made [ __ ] but he
talked for six hours straight
[Laughter]
yeah i think he distracted himself by
talking so much
i get all the plans drawn out and i just
talk at the camera manifesto style
speaking directly into it you had fun
though that's the most important thing
you didn't make anything and you're
gonna starve this winter but
man it was a fun ride but boy did i talk
a lot
so do you think that uh talking is like
a distraction or like a good thing
i mean i don't know i wish
i like
like obviously it's helped me somewhere
right like got me into stand-up it got
me into telemarketing you know like i
kind of i've always fallen back on
talking right just because i'm a chit
chatty dude i'm like a mom leaving
church just got so much to say
but it's also like you know
a lot of people go you should talk less
especially if i'm not you know doing
stand-up i'm just like sitting next to
him on a bus stop i'm in a chit chat i
can't help it i always have something to
say
yeah
people get annoyed by that but i think
it's like
the economic situation that they're in
where they're like oh i don't want to
talk to these people that are
my enemies and you know competition so
uh they have
they don't care about my suffering
um they they're just wasting my time
there we can't build solidarity we've
already tried
um
so yeah i mean i i'm not that much of a
talker so i think that's interesting
that you are and i feel like talkers i
tried to ruin the energy when i'm around
a bus stop and someone's talking and
just like awkward silences
uh and uh you know making it you know
really weird so that they don't want to
talk which is easier than talking so i
feel like it's sort of like a [ __ ] move
for me to be like
just i'd get you talking arms if you and
i were at the same bus stop god i'd get
you talking you would try to you could
put your headphones in you could look
down at your phone hey what are you
doing what are you surfing on what are
you listening to but it's not that like
doing push-ups in front of you do you
take satisfaction from that like oh i
got this guy to talk and he didn't even
want to
so when i was younger most my like best
friends were like introverts and it's
because like i you know would make it a
goal to win them over
so like yeah in my youth that was
something that you know if i i knew you
didn't like chit chatting people you
weren't chit chatting i'm like god i
gotta get this guy but now it's just
like a difference you're like oh he's
like this and i'm like that it's not
like he's worse or i'm better but it's
like i'm the guy that talks a lot more
than he does and also like you know now
that i'm [ __ ] like almost 30 this
wasn't the case in my 20s like almost 30
it's like you know you know some people
just don't want to chat you have to
respect them and treat them like that
right yeah so like
i think you want to chat once you know
that's like a podcast that's why you're
on stand-up well i want to chat with you
just at certain times you know maybe i
have like a crusty exterior where i'm
like get away oh i hate you but then if
you like get to get me to shh
then i'm like my mom never loved me
you know i just crack open oh yeah
that's i like getting to that in people
but some people
they don't want to hear it and i go all
right when i was younger i definitely
would just talk until they [ __ ] hated
me and now if i feel like someone
doesn't want to talk about it i won't
talk to you don't worry yeah i know that
uh some people i am just [ __ ] you
still want to talk to them you just so
badly you just respect them enough you
know where this ends up how it goes
usually biting my tongue right yeah
because some people you know there's
nothing wrong with them at all they just
don't like being chatted to they don't
like being shouted at they don't like
being asked questions you know what i
mean yeah and
treat others how they want to be treated
not how you want to treat them you know
yeah so boy do i just want to treat them
and talk at them but i'm like i gotta
treat people how they want to be treated
yeah because everyone says treat others
how you want to be treated but
that's not always the best it's it takes
more thought to be like oh what do they
want let me treat them like that you'll
win more you know you'll win more if you
treat other people the way they want to
be treated instead of how you want to
treat them you know
win more friends i think yeah or at
least you know win less enemies
yeah so now you don't talk uh to the
people that don't want to be talked to
as
much um try not to yeah
i mess up little i'm chatting i can't
help it but you do it because you love
people you want to find out about them
you're interested like this is another
person we could share information
partially also i like
i have this instinct where i just want
to try to entertain people you know i
mean i'm just like i just want to talk i
want to say something you know get them
all riled up or something you know yeah
get their attention you know yeah so
maybe there's a lot of selfish aspects
to it too maybe you saw in a really pure
heart way hans because you're pure heart
and you're like oh you care about other
people and getting to know them and i'm
like that but also you know i really
want
just to make them laugh try to get them
laughing a little bit
yeah because that's a fun game as
opposed to sit alone at a bus stop and
stare at your phone
it's better to play hey let's get this
stranger and you know try to get in
their heads and figure out what happens
inside of them
um but yeah i mean i uh i think it's
also asian to be like everyone stay in
your place go to the subway stand in
line next place
is that an asian thing yeah like if you
go to asia there's not a lot of jt
kelly's chatting up a storm wow
i would i would destroy their world i
would be chatting with everyone i'd be
arrested a wolf and a tennis sheep i
just dress as a wolf and get on a subway
yeah they don't have freedom of speech
there you can't just speech where speech
them to death korea oh i thought just in
asia in general i was like damn oh yeah
they don't have freedom of speech in
korea no it's a i don't know how many
countries like say that they had because
even canada don't doesn't say that they
have freedom france i don't think really
has freedom of speech either yeah it was
weird i remember the jeshu charlay
[ __ ] protest with all those countries
that don't actually support freedom of
speech marching with each other and i
was like weird yeah i mean germany you
can get uh arrested for doing nazi [ __ ]
which i think is is smart like i wish
that we did that after the civil war
were made if you did confederate [ __ ]
you get arrested yeah definitely a whole
lot less [ __ ] confederate flags
what you know what's wild about korea to
me
is that they're cia you know what the
cia in korea is called yeah
yeah the kci it's just called the
koreans like who started that that is
the funniest thing in the world
we were pretty down in the dumps when
america came to us we're like oh my god
we need something let's just take
everything from them their religion
their circumcision practices their cia
naming creative circumcision yes 90 99
95 no something crazy like that no
because because america does it yeah wow
i'm circumcised you circumcised yeah i
didn't really think much of it until i
saw some like cringe ass libertarian ass
protester downtown yeah and i was like
oh this guy's anti-circumcision that's
so weird it was the first time it ever
clicked for me i was like actually it's
not that weird and i was like
circumcision is kind of whack and like i
never even thought twice about it until
i seen this honestly just the cringiest
like libertarian style dude downtown
yeah in downtown austin
and it was [ __ ] like four or five
years ago and i was like whoa
circumcision is kind of lame i never
even like it's lame dude it's like kind
of crazy they do that yo this podcast
we're taking a stand is this live are
there people commenting uh-huh i just
want to check if the sound is working
um but where's this live team that's
kind of weird youtube oh wow we should
post it on instagram too but that i
would have to distract ourselves from
the conversation i'll just post it later
i like that there were people commenting
i never even thought that was a
possibility we live in the future baby
this is nice
maybe if they say something interesting
we can
incorporate it they're probably saying
the same thing
that's crazy they do circumcision and
cameras they don't even [ __ ] with
circumcision heavy in like england and
other parts of europe right yeah the
europeans got it all yeah they all about
the full penis in europe yeah that's how
you can tell european yeah well that's
one of the man the smell
just kidding
do they not shave their armpit hair i
don't care that's like a french thing
yeah i mean i trim it but like the women
there don't okay yeah mostly women here
don't anymore is it most or just like an
age group thing
um
yeah i think most do here probably most
it's weird if you don't
but it's weird that you do that's like
the new circumcision his armpit hair
it's a hot take
you should get a shirt on that plugin
armpit hair is the new circumcision
man do you wish you weren't circumcised
yes
deeply like is it well i have nothing to
compare it to but it's just
you know like
like we were born with it for a reason
yeah
and uh i've read up on some of it like
if you are [ __ ] a vagina and you have
foreskin then like the foreskin takes
the brunt of it and then your penis can
go into it
later you know like
it's like later
it was a good part
the
yeah
so it it like uh it's easier to [ __ ] uh
a vagina uh because uh it uh
you know it takes up the dry parts it
like sticks to the dry parts and then
your penis goes all the way into it wow
i remember in my friend group when i was
in junior high we only had one friend
that wasn't circumcised samuel
greenhouse and we were like maybe like
12 or 13 we're like yo let's see that
penis samuel and he showed us his penis
and it wasn't circumcised and we were
all like that is [ __ ] up like we were
just like that is the most [ __ ] up
it's like your penis done sucked up
itself you know i mean yeah because our
penis it was all the way out all the
time yeah circumcision oh yeah you're
out there your head's rubbing against
your jeans yeah wow and if you have that
little slinky on it
it's probably more comfortable with
jeans yeah bike riding
yeah yeah now you get less
or you could get more infections
depending on how
your hygiene is if you had a son
would you circumcise him no definitely
not i would have to because i wouldn't
want my son to have a better dick than
me
what if i knew my son had a better dick
i would be resentment and raising him so
of course i would have to get him
circumcised right off the gate so you
want him to live a shitty shitty life
hey that's not if
if me being circumcised is the shittiest
part of my life i'm doing pretty good
right
well i don't know like you uh you don't
want a better life for your son you want
him to just sort of continue the
traditions that you already have yeah
i don't even know if my dad's
circumcised i didn't ask him he probably
is probably i should call him you got it
when you're a baby
yeah it wasn't like a recent decision it
was like you know like i think eight
days we're not jewish but you know we
did the classic jewish thing have you
seen the little boards that they strap
babies to what it's horrific they got
like velcro and the baby's just like no
way yeah and their penis is out there
and then the baby's like wow where'd you
see this on like on some
anti-circumcision thing okay
wow it's a dark tunnel to dive down yeah
it's just completely you know
surgical it's like
so clean you could do millions of these
i
i read a story where a rabbi was sucking
the blood off of the penis after he cut
it yeah and he gave a kid like herpes or
hepatitis or some [ __ ] like a bunch of
them that's what i don't think there's a
bunch of them this is going to be a
one-off thing do they typically suck the
blood yeah the moil
sucks the blood out
yeah i thought and it gave like babies
herpes and the babies don't have a great
immune system so well they're babies
they're fresh in the world and they just
got their dick cut off so they got a lot
of they got like a bad case of herpes oh
man
that's wild i thought okay i'll be
honest with you i thought this was like
a couple rabbis i think it's one rabbi
and he did it to multiple babies okay i
i figure the first time someone sees
that they beg hey hey hey hey
what are you doing to my child
the fact that it happened more than once
lets me know okay a lot of people
involved got some issues
yeah it's not good to expose blood to
your mouth
no not at all also
you know i think we already touched on
this but we should be leaving those
[ __ ] babies penises alone
yeah just leave them alone in general
yeah it's just like what we think humans
are we're like oh humans have original
sin we got to change them so that
they're not natural and evil like the
natural world is evil we got to make it
better
if it was more of like an appendix thing
right where like it could explode at
some point right then oh yeah i take
that out but
it's just like cleaning actually
i thought maybe maybe this is propaganda
but i thought at one point
me i thought i heard a statistic that
was something like you're less likely to
get [ __ ] prostate cancer or some [ __ ]
like that if you're circumcised i think
there is like aids or something maybe
there's got to be some positive benefit
that was thrown around yeah for more and
more people to be like well this is
actually the positive thing
but my mom used to say god wouldn't have
required it of people
if it didn't have a positive impact well
what else does god record god requires
that you don't eat shellfish or wear
garments with two fabrics on that you're
seeing how where she was willing to draw
the line there right yeah yeah cut off
part of his penis but we'll cheat a
little bit on the shrimp yeah cheat a
little bit i'll be a little bad be a
little bad with the shrimp yeah that's
that's weird the two that's that's
another one that don't really make too
much sense to me cutting off the penis
and the two
fabrics that you can't mix together yeah
are you christians you grew up christian
yeah yeah i i feel like did you grow up
super super religious yeah me too super
super religious yeah super what type
presbyterian korean korean presbyterian
my brother taunted a korean church
briefly they were so nice to him yeah
they give him gifts all the time yeah
that's good they're very nice people 10
out of 10.
i mean it's like a tradition like gift
giving is like a whole thing gift giving
is a art form i didn't know koreans
invented that oh he did not i don't i
hope not i invented giving gifts yeah i
thought yo okay
you guys christian koreans give tons of
gifts though right i guess so i grew up
you know you seen jesus camp yeah i grew
up that type of christian okay
evangelical evangelical homeschooled
that whole thing southern yeah i have
super southern parents yeah my mom's
from mississippi my dad's from arkansas
you can just [ __ ] tell too so you're
saying the worship songs did you guys
have like a full piece band like
drums oh yeah super like super like
super emotional experiences during
worship that whole thing you know
loved it i want to see your hands in the
air
give it up for jesus
and then like they do the prayer with
the piano music in the background yeah
around the same time they're asking for
money yeah
they really know how to set a mood
they're getting the vibe just they're
doing something right that's the thing
they really are i heard that the incense
and catholic church that they swing
around used to be full of like drugs
that's tight and so everyone would be a
little
little a little stoned we got to bring
that back yeah you smoke weed yes we got
to do that but with weed yeah you know
because you can smoke weed in texas if
it's cbd
you know
yeah it's cbd they don't really care
anymore cbd yeah we got to do a cbd
church see if you do but then you want
to get us high
we'll just say it cbd oh yeah you go hey
this is a cbd wink
yeah
i went to a cbd shop and they had cbd
dabs and cbd shatter and i was like what
the that's the point all day yeah you're
just damaging your lungs you know
nothing real just do a fat [ __ ] yakka
dabs of cbd yeah i feel nothing
so much more now it's like smoking a
cigarette without any nicotine it was
incredible
what's the loudness of cancer those uh
those packs of cbd cigarettes are like
20 25 bucks and it's like bro just get
some marlboros just get like a marble 27
save some money yeah get a buzz to it
yeah get addicted what are the people
saying hans the confederates fought for
circumcision did they really
i'm sure they did you say anything
confidently i'll believe it
i am very easily a big part of it they
wanted to circumcise their slaves that
wouldn't surprise me my camera's a
little [ __ ] up right now
you have fixing it i don't know why i
offered help i wouldn't be able to do
anything but i think it's just a wi-fi
thing
um is mine [ __ ] up no yours is good
yes
well you know my facial expression
doesn't change so it's better that my
camera is all [ __ ] up
just put a picture up and see how long
it takes people to notice
that's hilarious
okay now it's back
man
i
there are there are new more cities that
still have like the confederate flag
hanging at their city hall right they
decided to take all this i think
mississippi was the last one that is
something mississippi just has the
confederate flag on their state flag
mississippi was so hard oh yeah you
meant like actual confederate flags but
yeah they took them down at all the city
that was like so recent too yeah it's
wild how recently that happened you
think it would happen after 9 11. like i
i think the slavery thing is worse than
the nazi thing and then with the nazi
thing they got rid of it right away
they're like oh yeah let's do a hard
180.
i thought you were saying just in
general that american slavery was worse
than what the nazis did and it's like an
interesting line to draw there i don't
really have a
really you don't need to compare it's
like weird comparison
let's have a suffering olympics
let's see who committed the worst war
crimes
for real i actually think benito
mussolini won
i know our opinions there it's wild
yeah but in terms of like length and
like what you had to do like yeah i mean
i think like chattel slavery it's like
yeah i mean it's
i mean they're both pretty bad both
pretty bad hey i think we can find some
common ground here both pretty bad right
yeah horrible things happen i know you
didn't expect this hot edgy take but
slavery dude and nazi germany yeah
pretty bad dude pretty awful i'll say it
crucify me okay i'll say it dude they
were bad oh what an edge lord i don't
like them
you're gonna get canceled for that one
bring it on dude bring on the swords the
swarms of people swordsworth
bringing storms the swarms that's worthy
go ahead dude
um
i i just think like it was such an
embedded part of our culture in the
1800s as americans and now it's like now
they got rid of it and they're like but
we still kind of we still kind of treat
people like that like walmart
and uh you know like amazon i mean even
as late as like the the 50s and 60s you
can i watched this like incredible news
story from i think it was the 50s where
a senator in mississippi had
sharecroppers living on his land that he
paid you know dollars per week there
and it was like reporters tv reporters
went and interviewed them and it was so
equivalent to slavery where they didn't
have any type of mobility they didn't
have any other types of options to where
it's like i don't know when slavery
ended like [ __ ] 50 60 years ago i
talked to a dude named nathan and his
granddad in bastrop had like you know
slaves were freed in bastrop and then
they just stayed because they had no
choice and they were intimidated so like
they had slaves until you know the the
again the 40s or 50s there when they
just their children's children died yeah
it's not like the south was like yeah
that was we were wrong sorry they were
like [ __ ] you guys you beat us but we're
still gonna
keep it keep it underground yeah they
had a very come and take it attitude
with the slaves as well yeah very common
taken attitude
yeah i think that's that's crazy i'm
glad that they did the civil war i'm
glad the north was like you're our
problem we're not gonna let you guys
dude we are going crazy with these hot
takes
we are glad the north won the civil war
me too
i could admit it yeah what a baller move
that was that
i yeah
i like uh i want to go to like a civil
war
uh battleground and metal detect it put
it up on youtube you know let the people
see what really happened out there
could do some real time investigation
some [ __ ] boots on the ground out
there yeah people don't know
i got a metal detector too beginning of
quarantine when i was like oh can't you
stand up got a metal detector i was like
rebranding be gonna be a metal detector
guy
that's that makes sense i used it like
twice
i told everyone else
i used it one time me and my bro went
out to like terra lingua to like uh a
ghost town right outside of terra lingua
and like an abandoned army base
and we found some trash it was sick and
we kept it found a railroad spike nice
horseshoe that's cool yeah
oranges are valuable back in the day oh
yeah we call those pioneer gold actually
i don't know i just found a couple
horseshoes and then one time the green
belt
yeah that makes sense
you should go to like somewhere historic
like the alamo
that'd be good they probably won't let
me dig up
i explained them with i'm actually with
the research team i'm with the
researcher
yeah there's a cannonball or something
there's got to be yeah is that metal or
i don't know what they made that out of
yeah gotta be right yeah there's got to
be some metal in it i don't think what i
don't think it was like rocks
yeah well i know like cement yeah
do they have cement back then
um but yeah i mean i think that's cool
um
i uh i would love to go metal detecting
why did we start talking about metal
detectors
oh you were going to go to civil war can
you go to a battleground metal detected
the north the north
i know a dude that lives on a house
built in the 1700s
and i was like in pennsylvania and i was
like damn i go metal detect that [ __ ] it
was like an old tiny hotel and i was
like that's a place i would like to
metal detect
yeah
you like find nails and then you destroy
a load-bearing wall this is from crisis
cross these are the nails from christ's
cross that's what i would claim
old nails yeah this is the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that they use to chop down a cherry tree
from george washington yeah i found
george washington's axe
he can't tell a lie neither can i
that's one thing we have in common
gotta be such a bad telemarketer if i
couldn't lie
so you lie continuously
like yeah yeah everyone does if you're a
telemarketer so much of your job is
lying yeah hi how you doing today good
to hear i don't care how you're doing
it's not good to hear you know
some business owner in iowa you know
yeah go column that's fun
it's a real cowboy job
i like to say i also like to call it the
trenches whenever i'm in the call center
welcome to the trenches right boys do
you work from home no i go to an office
uh
i used to work from home so you go into
the trenches and you meet up with all
your bros
that seems like a job you can do from
home it is
um
you don't uh you don't want to unionize
and
collectively bargain
i think that would be awesome i don't
think you know telemarketers are
probably gonna get that done hey if
there was a telemarketing union
organizing at the workplace i'd say what
is up but
i don't know
yeah you could have a strike and for
like a month you get the worst customer
service with all these scabs
maybe
i mean i think the thing is is such a
high turnover job that if you did like
at a you know at a telemarketing job
right cold calling job if there were
like you know murmurs of a union i think
it would get shut down pretty quick i
think everyone would be immediately
fired yeah yeah it's not highly skilled
labor
i mean
maybe i don't know i mean i think it is
but they don't it's definitely like you
know i don't know highly skilled to me
sounds like an electrician i don't know
what electricians know you know yeah
it's mostly just talking but i think
they would fire everyone so quick
i think it would not go very far
they don't respect their employees that
much they're like you're replaceable i
think that like
these companies tech companies build
their benefits package around trying to
avoid unions and so you have like what
you know seems like a really good like i
have today off because it's a federal
holiday right
but i i think that you know
without like if i when i worked at
juiceland i was totally trying to get
involved with unions
they did it i think they were talking
about it they i so i had the strikers on
my podcast when they first striked i was
overwhelmingly supportive of them i was
so excited for the strikers to strike
because i was like yeah strike you know
i mean strike take power so excited and
then they just didn't have a strategy
they didn't want to get connected with
the union they wanted to do everything
you know
kind of in their own new way
and it was weird i was i just fizzled
out they all stopped posting they all
stopped picketing
yeah most of them went back to work or
were fired for striking yeah
i mean
uh people don't want to sacrifice
anything um unless they know for sure
they're gonna get something
um i guess like yeah i mean it's hard to
know what to do and if you're not gonna
tap into a union that already exists
then it's like you're coming up with it
from scratch so you don't really know
how the how the story goes yeah and you
know to be clear that's a [ __ ] brave
thing they did right even attempting a
strike is like that's awesome you're
risking your livelihood and you're
asking other people around you to listen
risk your livelihood but they also kind
of had like a it's okay to scab opinion
so they weren't really asking people to
risk their livelihood they'll ab-risk
mind but feel no pressure to risk yours
and it's like in a strike if you're
gonna you know not show up for work you
really should beg of your co-workers you
know support us you know let's
let's really try to make an impact in
order for our needs to be met for our
demands to be met but
i think the their biggest thing was they
they one of their demands was they
wanted the owner to publicly admit that
he had done racist and creepy things
and he was like i'm not gonna [ __ ]
admit that like you gotta be kidding me
and so they were just not about it but
it just fizzled out i was excited for
them too
so now they're back to the same old
thing that they were doing in the
beginning some people in the warehouse
got raises from what i understand
and then i think that was the only
outcome okay
um i'm going to try to put my neck
pillow on good i like the way you pumped
that bad boy up
i'm going to read these comments
do you know history had so much
infrastructure tech that was
deliberately destroyed during every
recent war
i did telemarketing somebody
shedded their aid cells on me
hans don't be late for kill tony this
guy is going to give you a handy before
kill tony i hope you're talking about oh
that's the vantablack
uh hans for a face tat ooh i think you
could get a face dad you'd wreck one
you'd look great with a face tat
wouldn't everyone look great with the
face
maybe
i think particularly you would look
great with a face tattoo are you going
to kill tony tonight yeah are you doing
it's not because i thought it was like a
i've never
i've never even been oh i went to kill
tony a long time ago when i was at
spider house but i haven't been to it
since it's back
uh i thought it was antone's no years
years ago when they were touring they
came through and were on at spider house
tywin went up it was very funny nice you
watched the whole thing i watched some
of it i mostly i don't know was hanging
out at spider house just chilling yeah
but i watched
like comics i knew right you go in to
see comics you know and then stand
outside you didn't sign up yourself i
don't if i did i didn't get picked yeah
it was years and years ago
if i did because it was like is it still
like a bowl you pull a name from yeah
but you're on like the table tonight or
you're a future country regular so i go
up start it off oh hell yeah yeah
that's awesome i know i'm going up
usually
nice you get a minute right yeah and
then an interview okay it has to be a
whole new minute so i know that agabar
went on yeah that guy's a trip crazy
yeah yeah he was uh he was trying to
roast david lucas how'd it go
i mean he he was nonsensical like he
doesn't make sense yeah and david lucas
was like actually roasting and he's like
you look like a guy at a bus stop he
does terrifying
he used to have a youtube channel i
downloaded a lot of the videos on his
youtube channel because i was like yo if
this goes with delete i want to keep it
yeah
it's like what are you gonna do with all
those i just like to watch him i like
that he makes me laugh man you got good
content it is it is some crazy stuff
that he says and does it is something
where i go wow you are out there i love
that i live for that type of comedy you
know
[ __ ]
you ever notice how daffy duck and
donald duck be bringing their friends
around as if they own the place and i'm
going up to the sesame street characters
like hey man can you please give me a
dollar and they're saying agabar you're
always coming around here it's like what
are you talking about have you seen the
video of him in a white tuxedo no bro
i'll email it to you i will it is dude
it is so you got some of that premium
agape sweat my face is hot thinking
about it
it is good good
that's funny i mean i love your videos
the videos that you have on your youtube
like you're doing prank calls and you're
like shirtless or naked like doing
something [ __ ]
and it's just the audios playing over it
but you like to get naked sometimes i've
done it yeah done it for attention oh
yeah
i take off my shirt in a lot of sets
because i have that joke where i stick
my finger my belly button i scream like
lock the doors lock the door i just get
all like very agabar out there yeah um
so i do like marc maron yeah that looks
exactly like mark maron yeah
oh he has that quote i have a body type
where it's still funny if i take my
shirt off
like i take my shirt off it's
immediately like
okay you know all right what's going on
now you know he's definitely not proud
of this
no i it was an investment for comedy i
used to be ripped
and i invested in comedy by getting fat
yeah that's smart yeah your body is
comedy you're you're really inv you're
committing yeah exactly this is a bit
yeah i'm like a high level genius you
know this is a bit this is the real art
is you like suffering for your art i'm
like andy kaufman asked [ __ ]
yeah
so a little bit does that straighten
your boy out what's happening there um
so i have a herniated disc
sorry it's like this and then like a
little bit is poking out and touching
the nerves so if it's like pressing down
really hard then it squeezes out more
but if it's like loose
then it's like it's less
less uh pressure so it just prevents my
head from resting on my nice spine you
rock that for a certain amount of time
then you feel better for a certain
amount of time or is it only comfort
while you're wearing it
um yeah it feels better for a certain
amount of time it depends on my posture
too like usually
i have to sit down or lay down is the
best sitting is bad like sitting on a
stool
is bad but um standing up i can it feels
better but yeah if i'm sitting down then
yeah this is like yeah herniate that bad
boy
um jiu-jitsu you do jujitsu i used to oh
i do jujitsu nice yeah why what's why
isn't your body more
i've lost 30 pounds since november oh
you've been doing it since november i've
been doing it on and off for almost a
year to be honest yeah nice but like
when so my mom got really sick and i had
to go to california take care of her a
few times and i had to quarantine for 10
days each time i went out there and it'd
be like a week at a time or a month at a
time yeah so like technically i started
a year ago but i got like six seven
months of training all together but i
love it it's like my favorite thing my
neck hurts from jiu-jitsu too yeah
i'm doing a competition in april nice a
white belt thing oh yeah nice yeah
that'd be i wish i could do it it's the
ultimate sport in my opinion it's like
what every sport is trying to be how
long did you do it for
uh like a year or two oh no in town no
it's just all over the place okay bet
tennessee seattle mr worldwide over here
i love it yeah it was fun it's a hoot
and a half i was working door with a few
buddies of mine that like a lot of door
guys they get hired because they like do
like either semi-pro or kind of pro
fighting whatever but like bellator boys
and stuff like that and bjj boys they
work door guy jobs yeah and uh a buddy
of mine kind of recommended it said it
was really fun and i went to a class and
it was like this is i was like not only
is it fun to dress up you're wearing the
[ __ ] karate britches you got your
little pajamas on loved that felt like
oh this is so much fun yeah uh
first day you're wrestling yeah did not
expect that first day you're just on the
floor wrestling with someone i was like
dude this is i feel like i'm 12 years
old this is so much fun yeah it's like
the natural form of play for humans is
to wrestle you can't really box each
other without hurting each other so
humans wrestle that gorillas wrestle
each other and we're like taught you
can't don't you're hurting each other
stop touching
um but yeah i mean
now we can like play as adults it's it
really is it's so like
when someone asks like what do you like
about it it's like i don't know you're
just wrestling with someone it's like
yeah you could just grab someone like
hey
buddy the ground
it's so it's so cringe how much i love
it yeah it's a hoot and a half yeah
i'm bad at it too
because like for me it's like a lot more
pure yeah i'm just trying to lose weight
right yeah and so like i am i'm very bad
at it but yeah very like it's like dogs
at the dog park where i'm just like
heavy breathing trying to [ __ ] keep
my back off the ground
yeah you got to be on a side that helps
right
like there's like certain things that
you pick up you're like oh it's better
to have my hands in rather than you know
because if your hands are out here they
can grab it and it's funny
at first you're just trying to push
someone away yeah and then how many
times how quickly you learn to not have
your hands out yeah your instinct is
exactly that oh try to get off get off
me or get away from me and then just
grab your arm and do you know the
obvious thing yeah they just go for it
it's like oh yeah that's
kind of the first thing you'll try if i
give you my arm yeah and if you're on
your back it's harder to do things but
if you're on your side you can like
shrimp and like get away better
um and also like uh you don't want to
leave an arm and a neck in there but
yeah i mean i hurt my neck doing that i
um i went a little too hard i was too
excited i was too eager
um but yeah i mean i think i had bad
posture and like jiu-jitsu really
um
you know
found the kink in my armor
you want to know something wild
what about a year ago i'm on reddit
right i'm online baby i'm scrolling
through the bjj reddit and i see this
guy that posts something about doing bjj
and doing comedy and so i click his
profile and he's in austin and so i sent
him a message and i was like hey i do
comedy in austin too and i do jiu jitsu
and he says oh i go to this other place
in jiu jitsu and i really landed in
comedy a few times but then i see a post
that he made about being a 25 year old
virgin and he was just posting about it
and i was like
oh that was like someone i probably know
or interacted with is on here on reddit
trying to figure out how to have sex and
i was thinking about this a few days ago
and so i thought oh checking on his
profile i checked in right i swear to
god i'll show you this profile
in the past few months he has started
having sex with a girl who like wants to
have threesomes with him and like wants
to like teach him how to swing but only
with other women and i i'm going to tell
you you know what that was you know what
changed for him what jiu-jitsu he said
he got two strips and wipeout and i
think he just immediately was like i'm
gonna start having sex i don't need i
don't need the internet to tell me how
to have sex i'm gonna go out there and
have sex yeah cause a lot of it is like
people like i don't deserve it i'm not a
useful member of society i don't deserve
to be physically rewarded with pleasure
but once you're like
um i can defend myself and i am good at
something and i can see other people and
where they are and i i have worth like i
have like skills to get better at things
and they're like yeah i'm a worthwhile
person and i deserve
love i'm gonna go seek it out i can
actually i think it's something that i
can actually go get now yeah and also a
lot of people are physically afraid
they're like oh if i get in a fight what
if i hit on someone's girl or like like
once you start having sex with girls
it's like you're opening yourself up to
i don't know like the number one reason
people get shot is like you know
romantic stuff
really
yeah i believe that again if you say
with confidence i'll buy it well i think
it's like up there like that's why
parking and then like you're talking to
my chick or something that's i've never
associated like talking to women with
other men hurting me
so saying that is like damn do a lot of
deeds feel that way i'm not like a tough
guy too i'm very easy to beat up i've
been beat up plenty of times but you're
more like the social realm is like
you're more comfortable with it it was
not because of jiu jitsu that i had sex
if i had to wait for jiu jitsu i'd just
be starting having sex i'm just funny
i'm just you know just being goofy
you're like you enter you approach them
from like a social like uh you know like
a conversational thing as opposed to
like a physical like i'm stronger than
ever
if i needed if i needed to be like
strong or sexy to make women horny i
would never make a woman horny oh my god
i would never it would never happen for
me
i'm like practically married now so like
my life's great i don't have to yeah you
know be funny about that
you just have to play the long game just
like do the dishes and oh yeah keep her
happy oh like you know what i did today
it was my federal holiday and she had to
work did laundry man
juice her up she comes home and the
house is clean the laundry's done she's
gonna go wow i am juiced i'm clinically
juiced up right now that's what she's
gonna say that's attainable like having
to go up to a stranger that you don't
know and
say something that'll get her to have
sex with you that is that's what they do
i like forget i have to be nice to hot
women still like like i'm like oh right
oh my gosh you're still yeah sorry it'd
be nice again yeah
i got my chick's name tattooed on my
neck a while ago so i'm like locked in
i'm like settled yeah i uh i think
that's ideal
um that's what i every time someone
tells me they hooked up with someone or
they met a girl i'm just like you should
propose
yeah i just get out of it just propose
man yeah propose marriage and settle
down you'll be happier life will be
easier just propose marriage yeah
just i mean when you go out there and
you're talking to strangers it's like i
hope this person doesn't you know
destroy me for being emotionally
vulnerable but you never know and like
they don't care like they they're gonna
live their life without you tomorrow
they did it yesterday
like um it's it's like you're putting a
lot of power in their hands to these
strangers and yeah i mean most of the
time it works out but the one time it
doesn't can
you can be like well that's not worth it
damn it sounds like you're dealing with
heartbreak ons no it's just a game
theory this [ __ ] what's game theory just
like approach it like a game and be like
oh this is like
the stakes and this is the rewards and
just figure out if i actually want to do
it or not and that's why i don't like to
go out and to like places where
people don't where i haven't performed
comedy like i like i only exclusively
talk to people that know i do comedy
yeah i mean yeah oh my god i like yeah
when you make new friends it's almost
like you want to tell them like hey i
have a purpose you know i mean like i
have a thing that like brings me joy and
i mean it's like this yeah totally
there's a lot going on with me that you
can't see but there's a i don't have to
be good in the moment because i'm good
on stage so i'm going to just suck right
now but
take my word for there's something
awesome that makes up for how stupid and
boring i am
off stage
hey if you were stupid and boring off
stage hans i wouldn't be excited to be
here right now
well i wanted to have you on because of
the whole communism thing like i don't
meet a lot of people that openly admit
it most people are just like
you know i vote democrat i think that uh
you know like gay people should get
married but let's not go too far let's
take this don't be crazy i'm like no we
should own the means of production we
should own it we think we should own
those means yeah
someone's gotta own it yeah if someone's
got to own it it should be the people
working it that's how i see it yeah yeah
could be wrong but it sounds a whole lot
brighter to me
yeah i don't have all the answers but
that one seems like a pretty good one
right it seems pretty obvious seems like
the obvious you just want to let
billionaires um rule over us i really
don't man yeah i really don't
[Laughter]
i think we should all you know
work together is that crazy it just
seems like the future like everyone
voting all the workers uniting and being
like
uh deciding where what to do instead of
like just elon musk and jeff bezos
deciding to go to space isn't it weird
how much people just love those fools
too yeah like i'll never get over people
being like oh dude jeff bezos
i'm like you think those guys are the
coolest and like i have plenty of people
that i like i like and are cool fun
people that think that those guys are
the coolest they're not dumb they just
have different opinions than me but like
i talk to them and i really get down to
what they think about them and they
don't know where elon's wealth came from
or who developed all the ideas behind
his company or how he got tax credits to
build most of his wealth or you know
really anything about the history of his
business they just been sold by pr
companies as to how [ __ ] cool this
guy that [ __ ] a rockstar for a while
is and it's like yeah dude seems like a
dude that was balding left his first
wife even though he was rich you know
what i mean like yeah i don't know seems
kind of like a whack lame dude in my
opinion yeah
yeah he's he's just a normal dude i mean
he's not particularly that good at
anything like it's not like he got high
math scores or like we rewarded him the
money because he showed that he had
aptitude at something he was just good
at accruing money and getting people to
invest and sold them a story that they
like to hear yeah i guess that's pretty
smart right being a good salesman yeah
he would also like to have been a
rasputin dude yeah but he would have
been the rasputin dude of that time he's
a little more like tech techie or like
autistic he's a little more uh amoral
i mean i think i think that rasputin had
morals he was just like
sort of weird about it yeah but i mean
also like we don't have a very neuro
diversity
loving society like we just want like
jocks you know like
you know uh rappers goth jocks rappers
and stoners okay those are the four
appropriate styles to be yeah
but like in native american societies
they had like the shaman and the witch
doctor and like there was a guy who had
like a crazy dream about horses and they
all reenacted it for this guy and like
how great would that be if someone was
schizophrenic and the whole society was
like for one day we're going to like
live out your weird fantasy yeah the
horse dream guy yeah
i listen to you like that like in
thorough line podcast from npr
no they had a really good episode just
about how dreams used to be it's such a
big part of decision making not just for
personal people but it's like in
communities and [ __ ] like you're talking
about yeah where it's like it is until
recently that we divorced dreams from
reality i think that's interesting yeah
but i don't really dream i smoke weed
yeah me neither
i
deleted my dreams all gone yeah you
dream in real life now
[Laughter]
straight to sleep i just wake up eight
hours later nothing happened my brain
just turned off
stays
off yeah i think you do dream we just
don't remember it
because we're stoned yeah because we're
just so happy we're like
chill we're we feel like we're dreaming
when we're awake nothing to complain
about
yeah i mean i think dreams are like
represent the subconscious and we've
like
decided to you know only care about the
boring stuff and be mechanical robots
and there's no room in the eight hour
work day for people to talk about their
dreams yeah god didn't make me to stand
at a computer for 10 hours a day right
yeah just doesn't feel natural you got a
standing desk i do a standing desk yeah
that's good because if i sit down i'll
get tired you know if i sit down i'll
start
thinking
you know
relax and if i stand i'm working i would
work ten hours a day sometimes yeah
at five days a week sometimes yeah not
working today yeah that's good but i
yeah i work a lot of hours i usually
work extra because i'm a good worker
why do you work so hard make a little
extra money you know yeah in sales it's
like
you know it's like a hard job right it's
all commission all commission yeah so
it's like
the more hours you work the more
opportunity for money to make right and
so it's like unless i'm seeing the
numbers i want to see
then i stay late until i see the numbers
i want to see yeah
that makes sense i mean you uh you have
your time is like you can use it to uh
get the life that you want and
yeah yeah i'm just trying to you know
pay rent
about a
motorcycle oh yeah you think we're gonna
have a revolution
um no
i mean who knows i think it might happen
like uh
like the soviet union falling in 89 it
just suddenly just happens somehow
mm-hmm i think we could see the
beginnings of it in our lifetime but
i think that you know it's going to take
a while for the stuff to crumble but i
also think you know what do i know
remember you know last year when people
were burning down police stations you
know it looked like something really was
going to pop off right it was like and
we saw a similar thing in 2014
right and during the the ferguson
protest that pretty much every state had
large you know you you saw that energy
right where it was like okay people are
really sick of this but
they're really good at giving us
entertainment and options yeah that's
better yeah that's weird
um
yeah it's so weird how like all of our
momentum can be just destroyed like that
you don't think bezos is relatable to
anyone conor m
well you've never been a middle-aged man
oh man 40 year olds that are [ __ ]
rich and have young wives very relatable
look at canada
okay that's good advice
man what's going on in canada oh the
trucker protests
dude what's wild is there making it so
like canada is calling their banks and
being like don't let them spend money
the truckers yeah well people so i i
just saw one article headline i clicked
through read the article so i don't know
how common this is but it was just a
reporting on someone who had donated
money to
you know some sort of trucker-related
cause and then the bank was like your
funds are now on hold due to blah blah
investigation you're funding terrorism
yeah essentially i think that was kind
of the claim there well i don't agree
with the truckers but i also don't agree
with like
you know the banks being like you can't
send money here or there like the
truckers like you should they're they're
not what are they like honking too loud
i have no idea what the truckers are
doing they think they're blocking off
yeah i don't know what they're doing
it's just weird it's like yeah the
lockdowns are annoying but it's not like
the government that's the problem it's
like the disease like
this is what you have to do during a
pandemic like well they're mad at people
for like the disease and it's wild when
it started they didn't just give us all
10 000 and say everyone stay home like
i don't know that that remember when it
first was like all right dude flatten
the curve everyone's gonna stay home for
a month i was like okay but not everyone
can afford to do this and they're like
oh we're not gonna give you guys [ __ ]
anything everyone [ __ ] stay at home
two thousand dollar or one i forget it
was like a ridiculous one two thousand
dollar check like three or four months
in yeah you know what i mean and then
one
six hundred dollar check after that yeah
they were also cancelling their
insurance on their trucks and closing
down businesses of people that were fed
wow really
remember when you all thought russia
hacked the election yeah for real that
was crazy i know that wasn't uh yeah no
one smart thought that yeah that was
ridiculous that was the funniest thing
like how could you not see trump coming
like you don't have to hack the
elections i love the idea that like
facebook groups that were like started
in russia decided the election and it's
like okay well in that case we have
something much bigger [ __ ] bigger to
worry about right
like that's the actual case the [ __ ] out
of here
the [ __ ] out of here yeah
i mean i yeah yeah
yeah i mean the russia thing it was like
such a distraction is like the democrats
like not wanting to fix anything about
themselves and just blame russia instead
of being like yeah maybe we could elect
bernie sanders next
they just like sabotage just russia yeah
that was sad that was interesting
because i mean i wasn't like a big
bernie guy i can't lie to you and didn't
really give a [ __ ] either way but like
uh it was interesting watching him just
get sabotaged at every turn
and it was like damn they will never
give that fool a fair shot that was
interesting to me
he's like 84 now that was like his last
real shout out i remember i was in iowa
during the primaries i was on tour and i
was staying with this dude that went to
go be a part of the primary election
process and he was like they had
democratic [ __ ] like people that
worked for the democratic party there
trying to confuse the vote and make it
so and it was like that wasn't the only
place that reported stuff like that i
was like that's wild
i don't know the democratic party is not
that democratic
educate yourself a little bit more on
the pandemic this
global powers is what global powers
are using it to enrich themselves and
grab more power for themselves they want
to track everyone i don't think you're
wrong right inside of the ages right
they're using that as an opportunity to
consolidate power yeah if there's a
pandemic every good tragedy is an
opportunity or whatever absolutely zero
doubt about that but this also doesn't
mean that like we shouldn't do anything
for the we should do something like
donors that didn't vote for bernie
sanders don't really make i didn't vote
for anyone does that make more sense
you work as a telemarketer yeah
you don't really uh you know
like vote or
do anything like that man i want to
smoke weed with this guy inside of the
ages dude you come to wherever i am burn
one down chit chat that sounds like a
blast and a half probably won't agree on
a lot but i think you definitely have a
lot of interesting stuff to say you guys
are both chatters
dude you are clearly the same type of
chit chatting i have you got stuff to
say me too babe i love you in paragraphs
yeah i couldn't write this much i'd get
tired
go smoke
my hacker man get out of here
oh man
yeah i don't really know i wish i i i
don't know to be honest it's so hard to
find good news so like when i look at
the trucker stuff everything's so
intensely pointed in one direction and
so politicized that it's so hard to know
exactly what they're doing or what they
think but the fact that the government
and all them [ __ ] hate what the
truckers are doing it does make me go
okay so maybe they're on to something
but i don't really know the full the
full situation out there well the it's
kind of like the hong kong protest you
remember that where it was like so wonky
i'm just glad that someone's like
sticking up to somebody i like that
right i think you know just any anyone
being like being an outlaw being a rebel
i think that's yeah that shit's tight
[ __ ] the man yeah you know but i just
don't um think that they're on the right
track i mean they're not asking for
higher wages they're not like asking for
benefits they're just like we don't want
to wear a mask like that's it yeah or
like they don't want to get vaccinated
like if that's your only demand like
you're gonna you're gonna even if you
win you're not gonna get that much like
a lot of times those will be like the
surface level demands though right so
maybe there is something they're asking
for i bet inside of the ages knows
i bet he's typing this their exact
manifesto out of what they're asking for
right now he's saying you guys have no
clue what's happened to the
the freaking canadian truckers i don't
i'm gonna google it more i'm not gonna
go too much
yeah don't look too much into it i think
they're like kind of wrong about a lot
of things the truckers yeah i think yeah
yeah i mean i'm wrong a lot about his
stuff but i still want some people to
hear certain ideas i have well it's just
like they don't want to uh like actually
do it like labor
rights stuff they just want to like
organizing around labor yeah about
empowering themselves and their job and
yeah their line their industry right
yeah it's just like
they hate liberals so they're like yeah
the liberals suck or whatever hey
truckers you and i see eye to eye on
that nibble annoying just all get out
baby yeah it's funny my my like future
stepdad him and i were talking one time
and he was like so
how did you just end up so conservative
and i was like oh i want to call myself
conservative in the slightest bit but i
realized the only conversation him and i
had even close to
like political was when they first
started banning straws and saying it was
for
like turtles yeah and i was like they're
just businesses are saving money man you
know
there's just a bunch of liberals like
playing lip service to the environment
so they can restaurants can save money
they're even gonna start charging you
for straws i bet and he thought that was
just the funniest thing and so in his
mind he's like oh yeah jt's just uh he's
one of us conservative just like me yeah
he hates uh
business practices that
cater to
the more sensitive people yeah jt is
incredibly angry at the green washing
but i mean i think it makes sense to
like have straw whatever like
i think it's fine truckers don't need to
unionize union suck anyways maybe yeah
some unions are good something a lot of
unions are [ __ ] toothless but i don't
really know too much about unions i'd be
lying if i had a strong opinion on that
pretty much whatever one of your
commenters say i go yeah maybe man or
not who knows
chatter i'm just chit chatting i don't
like to argue i like to agree you can't
chat with someone if you're like no
you're wrong i know more than you like
you have to like sort of take it in and
like see how it feels in your head and
then like say something that adds
to their [ __ ] you can't just like reject
them and be like you're wrong i'd like
to think i'm open-minded i'm sure i'm
not to some stuff but i'd like to think
any opinion i'll hear and hear is like a
genuine be like okay let me try to
understand it yeah because they're wrong
it makes your communism more uh
you know respectable because like you
are open-minded to other things you just
happen to settle upon if there was
a better system
than like a planned socialist economy
you could win me over to it man i just
haven't seen it yet but if you got a
better system i'll i'm uh you know
[ __ ] i got into i read a little about
kinsey and economics for a bit and i was
like i don't really [ __ ] with that too
heavy
i was like oh maybe this one will win
but it seems to me that you know
decisions that are made by few should be
made by many right
yeah
so pretty straightforward to me yeah
decisions that pertain to the people
should be made by the people people yeah
uh-huh it makes sense man that makes
sense to me
i don't know i might sound stupid
thinking that does that make you a pinko
tanky for real man when i was younger i
was like very i'm a communist i'm a
communist organization i wanna as i got
older maybe it's like apathy maybe it's
just realizing i don't have the answers
but it's kind of like man yeah socialism
is great but how we get there i'm not
too sure yeah and it's like the
sacrifice that's required for whatever
marginal benefit to society is it's not
the equation doesn't work out if you're
going to start a revolution in the
united states right you're going to die
or go to prison right and so it's like
you want to die or go to prison
make a revolution from prison i guess i
don't know but people don't aren't
really about it they're like they
they're fine doing whatever they're
doing there's the
i think it's what the
weather underground was the term third
worldest where it's like the idea that
if there is a revolution has to
completely come from the third world
americans are bought out and as i get
older i'm like i think that's more
correct where it's like people in the
united states
you know we're soft or a cattle maybe
soft maybe cattle it's more like
i don't know if i have a good job i feel
like i have a lot to lose you know what
i mean yeah what's that what's that
thing it's like some idiot idiom you see
online where it's like everyone in the
states doesn't know they're poor they
think they're about to be rich oh yeah
everyone in america
thinks that they're temporarily
embarrassed millionaires yeah i think
that's you know i wouldn't say that's
necessarily me but i feel like i'm i get
that i totally get where they're coming
from where it's like my goals now are
like oh yeah get a good job you know buy
a house one day you know have a kid
yeah i mean you have to live a life you
can't just always like think about the
collective and what everyone else should
be doing but like you have to live the
life because we live our lives
individually we don't we're not a hive
mind yet yeah
yeah
yeah what are you planning
uh neurolink we're just gonna link up
and
like every individual is just gonna be
like a little ten percent chunk of
the consciousness of these species do
you think that like
like science and tech and stuff like
that and like the internet is gonna
bring like awareness and tools to the
workers and stuff like that
there's that there's a famous marx quote
where he says some [ __ ] like you know
the the chains at some point the chains
of oppression will become so heavy we'll
have no choice but to throw them off but
then i heard someone say one time that i
was like i think that's a little more
true that it's not that the chains
became so heavy it's that they became so
intertwined in our life we don't even
realize that they're chains right and so
some people look at like you know the
the tech companies and like all the the
the the companies where it's like yeah
we can all from on on blockchain decide
who gets voted for who and there can be
no stuff like that and they kind of see
hope you one of those guys that see
hopes sees a lot of hope in like tech
development like tech might save us and
give us democracy tech might give us
socialism i mean i think tech can help
but i think the thing that uh we have to
actually do is just as people decide
like have a critical mass of people that
decide to change things
tech can help in that but it's
it'll it's a it's a tool
the real thing that we need is like
people to
decide what they want to do for their
future
instead of just letting it happen but i
think most people like know what they
want in this world i think most people
know you know i mean i think most people
know that there's a [ __ ]
you know boot on their neck i think most
people know like yeah dude the man
[ __ ] keeps us down i think most
people i feel like that's kind of a
generally agreed upon thing where it's
like yeah dude we live in a wonky time
we're weak but then why do like some
people like yeah the lead are keeping us
down but uh
elon musk and uh jeff bezos like they
got to where they are legitimately i'm
just trying to become like them the
bootstrap mentality that i'm that what
we were just talking about the whole i'm
not poor i'm just gonna be rich soon
thing yeah i think a lot of it is like
pr bro i think like you know people
that like that story's been sold to us i
think that story has been 100 sold to us
there's no other myth like it's not like
there's a like if you don't believe in
the american dream it's not like there's
something that replaces it it's just
like oh well then yeah you just been
[ __ ] for the last 400 years and
yeah now you're here so there's a
there's like a famous
i don't know how famous it is but i've
seen it um where it's like there's a cia
like memo where they're talking about
they're like we don't we want everyone
to know if they're going to be you know
communists or revolutionaries they're
going to be dead you can be a famous
actor you can be a sports player i think
it's talking specifically about black
people and it's like you can have good
jobs and like the cia was very like
let's you know promote that
that's the dream yeah that's socialism
like everyone getting good jobs and
having a living they're like no we can't
have them be socialists so let's give
them socialism that's hilarious sell
them a false idea of socialism yeah
because i mean like job rate could be
100 we could all have good jobs there's
a great propaganda from the
revolutionary communist party of the
americas in the 80s where they say where
it starts out really big and it's like
see how there's so much work to be done
but there are no jobs and it's talking
about like the bad roads the bad schools
you know i mean poor neighborhoods
there's so much work to be done but work
isn't decided based on what needs to be
done is decided on what makes profit and
so that to me is just so straightforward
where it's like yeah dude maybe profit
shouldn't drive us
you know maybe what's necessary
like there should be profit somewhere in
in the society that we live in maybe the
healthcare shouldn't be making all that
money right people that own [ __ ]
pharmaceutical companies maybe they
shouldn't be driven by profit right yeah
some industries are more uh prone to uh
what is that called like negative uh
perverse incentives yeah like education
is a wild one to me where it's like damn
so colleges just like compete with each
other and cost money and instead of
getting better they just get more
you know difficult to get into unless
you're rich you know
it's wild yeah
it's uh yeah i mean it's obviously
because of profit because people want to
make more money william said yes jt
thank you
someone used my name that's crazy i
don't know you guys it's on the uh
title of the thing oh i was like damn he
just remembered that from earlier
like i wouldn't
he's like yeah i remember that from
earlier that's wild impressive yeah
maybe he uh
isn't using it on full screen
he just got it on
the little youtube players the names
constantly there or maybe he like moved
this mouse and then the name pops up
wow
so much text of it so impressive to me
i recently learned how to put links and
emails and like hyperlink it just a
button on the email you push but you
highlight what you want to put the link
on and then that word becomes
yeah someone showed that to me and i was
like wow
the future that's how they do it i
thought you had to go to a website where
it gets done for you
do you say gift for jif
uh graphic user interface or a graphic
interface what is it the
actual so i think i say gif because
that's like the word
graphic isn't there
so when i seen
on tumblr years ago there was an option
to turn a video into a gif and i was
like damn this is good and then i don't
know if tumblr stopped working or if it
fell off i stopped using like 2014 or
whatever um
but that was like the only time i made a
gif and i was like damn i really did
something here
turned a video into a picture video i'm
back when yeah and they had to go
through like run programs on it and
stuff i was like that's something yeah
it makes it more shareable you knew a
goth girl when i was in ninth grade
stephanie and stephanie she made her
profile picture on myspace a gif i was
like you are that isn't
very impressive stuff it's like a
[ __ ] one of those harry potter
paintings that move around
that was the same level of impressive
that type of magic for me for real
that's awesome just
show you having sex going in and out so
it looks like it's continuous
forever remember how long if you were
gonna watch porn like a really long time
ago when it would be like if it was a
video it would take like
seven eight minutes to load and if it
would be like a two minute video on that
website yeah
i remember the pictures i like i used to
go to sports illustrated nice and i
didn't want to like click on the links
so it would turn purple in your face
yeah so i just copy pasted the urls
but then i realized that if you hit s on
the url bar then sports illustrated
women naked shows up so it's it was
actually even more it's probably better
just to have that because they're never
going to go to sports illustrated but
they might hit us on the url definitely
going to hit ass on the kind of [ __ ]
myself you really did i used to go to
ebay
and search studs or kink or something
like that and it would show women in
like lingerie that's how i would get
around ebay yeah if you go to ebay at
the time and like pretty much look up
like bdsm lingerie you could see like
nipples
it was it was the closest i get to get
to porn without like my parents being
like yeah what's nude women.com jt you
know you're just looking on ebay and if
they did look it'd be like oh yeah he
was just looking at studs for his stud
belt or something digital shopping yeah
i was just doing some digit mom i was
doing my digital show
i was participating in e-commerce mom i
was i was partitioning on the new
frontier of e-commerce mom
i remember i bought a tony hawk dvd off
of ebay and it came in broken and so i
returned it my parents were like that's
why you don't buy stuff offline but when
i returned it they sent me a free game
with it as like an asari and my parents
were immediately won over to buying
stuff online they were like buying stuff
right
like oh this is a human thing it's not
just like robotic yeah
yeah now my mom actually buy everything
online yeah everything they were late
i've been buying stuff online
stay buying stuff online now i was even
uh looking at things i wasn't gonna buy
online because it was porn just like to
think about it yeah i did so i got some
adidas shorts
um not to name drop adidas is that your
favorite brand because you're wearing it
right now it's just like cheaper than
nike to be honest i like nike and adidas
and all them brands but like
it's just this is just usually it's
comfortable it's athletic cool it's
athletic i like carhartt too yeah you
know of course you do of course i do man
i like what's uh my favorite brand right
now
dickies
nice that's like carhartt it's like
carhartt it's like cheap carhartt
cheaper car exactly that's like dickies
and car hearts like adidas and nike for
me i like them both but i have more
adidas you know yeah got this at a
thrift store for damn near nothing the
adidas
nice yeah again bragging
but i got adidas shorts offline like
eight bucks for karate i love to call
jiu jitsu karate because i like to
people imagine me doing adult food
that's what you do in your videos you
really like karate i do karate pages
yeah that's funny the well when i first
put on the like outfit i was like no way
i was like i can't
do this this is unreal
it was sick it's so much fun uh
but uh
i got i got a car i got like a deal of
shorts and they have zippers in them so
you can't wear those to jiu jitsu right
because you'll zip someone up so that's
my online buying stake i can't return
them because i tried them
on so just like right why don't you tell
them that you didn't try it on
you keep my line on telemarketing all
right
i keep i mean my life if i got a lie
it's going to be on the you're afraid
that you're going to give someone herpes
like the
the jewish moils yeah i'm afraid you'll
be able to sell my penis
this guy's circumcised
well
i don't know it just seems like not a
big deal that you tried it on like is
that a rule do they say if you try it on
you cannot read i took it out of the
packaging i took all this stuff off of
so it'd be like is it an amazon thing no
it's like it's an amazon style site but
i just bought
i literally went into google and i was
typing in because i was buying new rash
guards yeah and some i bought a bunch of
hawk rash guards off some website what
kind of people are selling uh jiu jitsu
gear with zippers on them that seems
it wasn't a jiu jitsu specific site it
was like a
workout gear site because even like the
hawk rash guards those are for surfing i
think okay but they're cheaper than
buying like a g also if you go to like a
jiu jitsu website and you buy a rash
guard it's like the most like ed hardy
giant
explosions like uh george washington
riding a dragon shooting a gun up in the
air it is the most like gaudy clothing
those guys go cry did you just use fun
but like the style around it like the
dudes like that you look like fresh
guards i'm talking about yeah they they
got like a lot of detail there's like
patterns on it which is fine do your
thing buddy but it's like those are more
expensive than just getting one that's
black yeah yeah just like have a normal
color
so you don't have to stand out because
your rash cards are weird yeah and again
you want you want some goofy rash guards
my god go hard get your goofy rash guard
on i got nothing but i'll be shoulder to
shoulder with you yeah you wear your
goofy but it shouldn't be the norm but
it's like thirty dollars and you can get
a like a hawk you know rash guard 10 15
bucks a ruka are you you know the ruca
company ruka you're
i worked at a menswear store when i was
19.
it's like brazilian isn't it no idea
okay i don't know that much about it
rvca yeah it reminds me of like a radio
uh
you know like a company that does like
vcr stuff rvca yeah
um but yeah i see it a lot you know
that's how you know
uh someone does jiu jitsu or like that
brazilian brand
that has like that logo
something like that i forget
um
uh but yeah i mean yeah some of those
brands you're like oh this guy rolls he
can probably murder people with his bare
hands i seen my gym was selling like
sweaters
like that were like gym specific
sweaters you could buy and i was like
man there's a white belt i don't want to
wear that because of the reason that
you're thinking like a jiu jitsu guy
sees it like ah yeah let's get rowdy and
i'm like oh i'm like you'll throw me on
my back
i know like you don't want to put that
out there yeah it's like opening
carrying yeah oh my god i'm a gun guy
putting like gun stickers on the car is
like
it's not tactical it not yeah not only
that people are going to break into your
[ __ ] car and steal your guns man if
you have a gun in there you got a
sticker on there you're saying okay i
got 400 freaking gun in my car get out
of here man that's wild i see those all
the time gun bumpers stickers
and it's like yeah dude you're saying
steal my gun that's what i see same with
shirts and stuff dude i would never wear
like a glock shirt you know what i mean
just because it's saying like i have a
gun on me yeah you don't trust people
but maybe if you lived in a society
where people weren't gonna murder you
you could be like i love guns and i love
wearing this shirt i love what it
represents i love having guns i got the
gun tattoo this is one of the dumber
ones i got that when i was like
yeah only got that one i was like 20.
there's a communist weapon and 20 year
old me was like you know what i should
get actually i didn't know my buddy's
idea he's like i should tattoo an ak on
your arm and i was like dude that sounds
awesome
i was like that to me dude that to me
sounds cool let's do it do you have guns
i recently registered to vote just so i
could buy a gun what you had to register
to vote to buy a gun well because they
need like government uh a government
form saying that i live in texas because
i have a washington state id
so this is going to be my inn and i'm
going to go to a gun show
in texas you can actually buy and sell
guns without any proof of who you are
completely legally i go into when i got
if i wanted to get a gun hypothetically
yeah if i wanted to get a gun completely
legally
i would just google gun show texas and
then drive out to the one that's nearest
because there's one every single weekend
kate taylor kyle all that and just go to
a booth and a dude just privately sells
me a gun he doesn't ask for my id
we just exchange cash are you worried
that it's like used and maybe the spring
is a little wonky
i've like i've bought gun show guns and
like
i'm not like a gun expert i can't even
pretend to be but like i i feel like
i've been shooting guns since i was like
four years old that's when i shot my
first gun i was like four
so like
if a gun's wonky i think i might have a
good idea of it but maybe i'm just
setting myself up to be scammed well
yeah i mean i just don't want to like
guns are kind of scary so i want to buy
one like
that's in the packaging
you know fresh i don't want to buy like
a toyota camry
gun
that's used on craigslist i got like my
first gun my dad bought it for me when i
was like 11. and it was like an antique
gun from a sporting goods store it was a
communist gun has a hammer and sickle on
it it's most in a gun from
your dad bought it i thought your dad
was like super christian he's super
christian yeah he's super republican
still a cool gun i was a little kid he
wanted to get me a cool guy that's an
incredible weapon it really is and that
started you on the path of communism
that hammer and sickle i said now what
does that mean i don't know are those
guys the good personality now
think of new identity unlocked
for real
you just press it you get all these
ideas downloaded anytime someone says
something like oh i hate communism i'm
like okay that's fine but
i always like to say like yeah it's
really interesting when fascism was
stopped at reagan grodd oh no i guess it
was stalingrad
and people get all defensive about like
oh was it was it liberal god no it was
stalingrad that's where the nazis were
stopped
[Laughter]
people especially if you know a lot
about history try to argue with me i'm
like i don't know enough about history
to argue with you
i said what i need to say
how did you set that up like i forgot
anyways but like yeah because that was
stalin's city like he it was named after
him so he really didn't want to so he
was like throw everything at them at my
city because there was like leningrad
fell i think
i thought it went my hair i thought it
was so-called st petersburg and then it
was called linen grad and then it was
called stalingrad and it's called moscow
[ __ ] okay i don't actually know that
though that's just me guessing oh really
they they stopped them in moscow i
thought it was like before they got to
moscow who knows
i feel like if a dude read a history
book he would know
one of those dudes well it was uh yeah
enemy at the gates with jude law
i forget what city it was
i like we're the same type of dude
because you thought read a book and you
thought a movie about the event
read a book no no no no no a movie about
the event though i'll watch that [ __ ]
all day
it's got pictures that move
it's funny netflix came out with a
documentary about the branch davidian
waco situation yeah and it is
surprisingly anti-fed which is like not
a common stance right that's like not
the narrative stances that they were you
know wrongly
burned oh yeah just you know slaughtered
through burning but my chick watched
that little not it's not even a
documentary it's like a
novella style telling of it like a short
short uh a short series like brand of
brother style and my chick was like
that's crazy what the feds did to him
and i was like that wasn't even a
documentary you just watched a movie
that stylized what happened
sick people are that's how we we tell
stories that's how humans you know
narratives exactly
um so did you want to do your podcast
let's do it or let's what time do you
have to be at
um it's 6 p.m
roberts
so
you're like uh he just sent me the link
for the thing i feel bad well i'm gonna
tell him because you have to leave it
what time seven okay
all right hans good podcast the good
guys until they weren't thank hey age of
reason hit me up or age of whatever you
seem chill you seem like a chit chatty
dude
my guy saying anarchy